[Music]  thank you that's Kim Kardashian sisters  Kendall and Chloe pointing out her  slimmer figure at a charity poker  tournament I've never seen a skinnier  person in my life takes work to look  like that that's amazing now Chloe is  coming to Kim's defense after haters  slammed the family's comments on social  media you know and I'm like it's not  that serious guy Coco seemed unfazed by  the backlash and clarified her comments  telling enews quote she looks great and  I'm praising her for looking good adding  I think people are taking those comments  so far it's also we're teasing each  other too  I'm not that skinny I'm down to 119  pounds  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]